on
prend des microns prend pas des fans ntm
au cinéma un biopic est consacré au
célèbre groupe de rap français suprême
c'est le nom du film revient sur les
débuts du lot
[Musique]
1987 didier morville et bruno lopes
répète dans un local leur titre je rappe
la vingtaine originaire de saint denis
ils sont inconnus du grand public
un an plus tard en 1988 ltn écrit à
l'époque le rap venue des états unis
n'en est qu'à ses prémices en france il
écrit que diffusé à la radio ntm trois
lettres pour l'i ppte amer mais pour
joey starr ce n'est pas une insulte
plutôt un cri de protestation
c'est la seule façon qu'on a trouvé de
se faire remarquer en plus je dire c'est
une expression qu'on utilise tous les
jours qui
tu peux être l'équivalent de zut ou
merde oui comme des gens qu'ils prennent
au premier degré c'est regrettable leur
parole dénonce de racisme l'état des
banlieues les inégalités sociales
j'arrive pas tous les jeunes qui ont la
possibilité de parler et qu'on puisse
capter notre truc ce qui veut dire donc
eh ben on en balance
en 1991 c'est la sortie de leur premier
album authentique un énorme succès cent
mille exemplaires vendus n'a pas
seulement le fait de rap et de et mais
octroie aussi un mode d'expression
je crois que nous serons plus forts
1993 sortie de leur deuxième album
1993 j'ai appuyé sur la gâchette un
disque engagé polémique
l'un des titres racontent un suicide
scandale
la radio bout de la chanson la télé le
diffuse le clip qu'après minuit c'est
pas un appel au suicide sans appel à la
réflexion tout court à regarder autour
de soi voilà la bo de gens qui ne vivent
pas comme nous l thème sortirait un
troisième album en 1995 paris sous les
bombes puis un quatrième en 1998 suprême
ntm le dernier du groupe
obtenant domaine pour l'egypte le même
deal bourse muqui
[Musique]
c'est un énorme carton l'album le plus
vendu du groupe lui cent mille
exemplaires écoulés c'est un exutoire
pour décrire ggyc
une vache mention que que la musique ne
changera pas vraiment les mentalités
fait sinon peut-être qu'on écrira des
bouquins offrait pas de la musique
derrière en 2001 c'est la fin des tn
joeystarr et kool shen se fait par le
duo s'est reformé une première fois en
2008 une seconde fois en 2018
mais juste pour interpréter leurs
anciens morceaux au total ntm a vendu
plus d'1 25 million de disques en france
[Musique]